we're about to have fire poops all day
long yay fire poops
[Music]
it smells like ridiculously spicy in
here imma both scared and excited I
wasn't a navy before so I think I would
be fine
this is a challenge and we're gonna do
this without milk okay I'm a little
nervous this is literally just hot
peppers do you see how thick these
slices are sorry mom you first was all
done yes their toes ah saltybet so far
huh I get the hiccups when I feel pretty
alive you know just hitting it nice and
burning over here it hits your tongue
you're like oh I can do this and then
it's like hi we gotta finish the shower
head yeah I wasn't an amazing before
something old before my eyes are
watering my nose is dripping I don't
want to take another bite this is what
being on fire who eats this I don't
think you need a Kylie Jenner lip kit I
think you just need to eat one of these
tacos milk doesn't work whose idea was
this I'm not mad I didn't finish because
it hurts cards were stacked they were
not enough Ava
hey when seriously though I am NOT
looking forward to town now I'm pooping
I really want hot wings now I passed the
common sense test of not eating this
anymore I might have felt this taco
challenge I'm walking out of here with
dignity and respect
[Music]